[Música]
todos nacemos y no elegimos ni dónde ni
cuándo ni cómo ni por qué lo elegimos el
contexto social ni las condiciones
económicas nuestro entorno nuestros
padres familiares tampoco elegimos
nuestras primeras experiencias en la
vida esto mejora con el tiempo pero
tampoco cambia porque seguimos sin tener
la capacidad de decidir qué cosas nos
pasan
sin embargo sí que podemos elegir y
decidir qué hacemos y cómo nos
enfrentamos a aquellas cosas que nos
suceden y yo he elegido transformar mis
experiencias negativas en experiencias
positivas nutritivas en experiencias
transformadoras como
yo generando ficción audiovisual
transformando mis experiencias en
entretenimiento y a través de ellas
poder romper con los tabúes y acabar con
el silencio
es verdad que es muy fácil decirlo y es
muy complicado hacerlo pero tengo una
buena noticia no estamos solos me
explico
yo me di cuenta de este poder que
tenemos gracias a una experiencia que
viví cuando era pequeña y que fue
silenciada
yo sufrí abuso sexual
hecho que no recuerdo pero que siempre
he sabido estaba en mi cabeza lo sabía
pero como nunca nadie me había dicho
nada pues pensaba que me lo habría
imaginado que me habría soñado
me da miedo preguntar
porque pensaba que iban a decir que era
una mentirosa aunque
sé que me inventaba las cosas para
llamar la atención
me da miedo que me criticarán que me
señalarán
se rieron de mí pero a la vez sentía que
guardaba un secreto
sentía que mentía a todo el mundo que me
rodeaba desde el minuto en el que les
conocía les estaba mintiendo
aquí la ironía mentir para que no te
pasen de mentirosa
a medida que crecí y cuando ya tocaba
dar con los chicos yo me sentía muy
incómoda odiaba que me echaran piropos
me extendí a no estaba justo
de hecho recuerdo que cuando me estaba
con alguien siempre
estaba incómoda
porque aunque mi cabeza no se acordara
el cuerpo si tiene memoria y trataba de
huir en cualquier situación parecida
yo me sentía atrapada y era un
adolescente que se esforzaba por ser una
persona normal
ya los 22 años
me volví a encontrar con esta persona
que abusó sexualmente de mí
todavía me cuesta decirlo en voz alta
bueno pues cuando me encontré con esta
persona acabé discutiendo con ella por
un tema que no tiene ninguna importancia
pero sentí una fuerza animal que me
invadió y que le habría matado me lo
habría cargado
la primera vez en mi vida que siento que
soy capaz de matar a alguien acabar con
la vida de una persona
me asusté muchísimo tanto que fui
directa psicólogo
la psicóloga me recomendó que hablara
con mis padres que les preguntara si lo
que yo pensaba que había sucedido era
real o no
así que pregunte
no quería saber la respuesta pero lo
necesitaba
y efectivamente era real había sucedido
pero nunca a nadie me había dicho nada
porque como pensaban que no me acordaba
y lo que no sé dije no existe pues para
que todo el daño que yo me estaba
haciendo por dentro no importaba pero
para mí fue un alivio porque ya sabía
que no estaba loca
fue muy duro porque aunque una parte de
la familia que me apoyó
incondicionalmente
hubo otra que me dijo literalmente
dejar de remover la
hay gente que lo ha pasado peor y
barbaridades similares que ilustran a la
perfección la sociedad en la que vivimos
en la que todo lo que es negativo se
silencia porque es más fácil
pero estimo una cosa habiendo vivido
algunas situaciones os aseguro que es
mucho más fácil
hablar que contar
pero el más allá
hablando con mis amigas
y poniendo en común me doy cuenta de que
casi todas han pasado por algo similar
lo que pasa es que nunca habíamos tenido
el espacio para hablarlo entonces
yo me pregunto por qué nadie habla
porque somos cómplices de este silencio
porque nos da vergüenza
porque quien nos va a creer
porque tenemos miedo
porque hemos normalizado el silencio se
ha convertido en algo estructural que
afecta a muchísima gente y que traspasa
generaciones repetimos patrón
pero nuestras manos está cambiarlo solo
tenemos que abrir la boca
después de muchos años surcando la
niebla sobre todo aprendiendo a quererme
otra vez
siento que una nueva energía en la ave
que resurge de sus cenizas me invade
siento que vencido el miedo que he
abrazado la vida tal y como me ha venido
y que puedo seguir adelante es más
siento que tengo el deber y el poder de
desnormalizar el silencio porque a mí
personalmente es lo mejor que me ha
pasado
para ello recurso medio llamado bikini
burka y publiqué un artículo
el día que se publicó el artículo
yo estaba
nerviosísima ya no eran solo mis amigos
mis familiares conocidos los que iban a
saber lo que me había sucedido sino
gente desconocida que no me conocía de
nada y que podía juzgarme sin ningún
problema
en mi cabeza se llenó de pensamientos
me van a señalar con el dedo se van a
reír de mí y voy a ser narrada nadie se
va a querer acostar conmigo nunca más no
me van a tocar ni con un palo
por suerte
no fue así de hecho sucedió todo lo
contrario
el artículo se hizo viral
mi cuenta de instagram se llenó de
mensajes de gente que
me decía valiente eres una valiente
y yo les decía no
valiente es haber estado callada gente
que decía que me admiraba porque ellos
también querían hablar y yo siempre les
he animado
a día de hoy siguen llamando a la
revista para contar y compartir sus
experiencias
el otro día llamó una chica
qué bueno mi artículo le había inspirado
para
contarle a su madre que habían abusado
de ella sexualmente
y su madre le confesó que ella también
había sufrido abuso sexual
y por parte de la misma persona
tal vez si la madre hoy está hablado en
su momento su hija no habría pasado por
lo mismo
la cantidad de gente que compartió su
experiencia me entristeció muchísimo
porque hay mucha gente que ha pasado por
esto pero a la vez
me hace sentir un poquito mejor porque
me sienta acompañada siento que no estoy
sola siento que no soy la rara que no
soy anormal
y así es como me di cuenta del poder que
tiene hablar alzar la voz comunicar y ya
no solo hablar con nuestros amigos
familiares no sino que yo soy actriz y
guionista
puedo utilizar mi profesión como
vehículo para contar todas aquellas
historias que la gente no quiere
escuchar
así que reviste todo lo que había
escrito por mi cuenta hasta el momento y
me di cuenta de que ya lo hacía incluso
desde el humor
tengo una serie que se llama crónicas de
una actriz superviviente que narra el
día a día de una actriz que intenta
hacerse un hueco en la profesión todo
esto parte de la idea de que vemos a los
actores en la alfombra roja con sus
galas rodeados de lujo su glamour pero
no vemos lo que hay detrás no puedo
pagar las facturas estuve trabajando en
un mcdonald's hasta el día antes de que
se estrenará la serie que protagonizó
y cosas parecidas también luego va
acompañado de un proyecto que es el anti
curriculum que son entrevistas a gente
del sector en las que cuentan lo que
jamás pondrían en su currículum del tipo
la en un casting porque me quedé
en blanco
puse verde a un director y resulta que
estaba hablando con él
o el año que estuve nominado al goya no
podía pagarme el alquiler y dormía en
los sofás de mis amigos
con todo esto intentamos contar todo
aquello que la sociedad no cuenta lo que
se oculta porque todo el mundo somos
personas normales con vidas con
problemas otro proyecto es una obra de
teatro en la que todos los personajes a
través de su discurso legitiman sus
actos por ejemplo mariah la sanguinaria
bloody mary en mano y nos valida los
actos por los que ha sido juzgada así
intentando así limpiar la imagen que la
historia él ha creado otro es una mujer
embarazada que no quiere ser madre y que
ha sido criticada y juzgada y nos expone
sus porqués y la comprendemos y la
respetamos y es que este es el poder que
tiene la ficción
nosotros como espectadores
guardamos una distancia de seguridad me
explico
no es mi hermana a la que han violado no
es anna la hija del pastelero josema que
encarna el actor este que me gusta tanto
no es mi padre el que es un alcohólico
no es pablo el marido de sonia que
claramente es un borracho muy agresivo
no es mi hijo el que es homosexual
que no pasaría nada pero mi hijo no es
homosexual es álvaro este personaje que
nos encanta que todo el mundo le adora y
es que les escuchamos les comprendemos
empatizamos igual no estamos de acuerdo
pero les respetamos
y luego apagó la televisión salgo de
cine del teatro cierro la novela y me
voy con mis amigos a tomar unas cañas y
desconecto o no incluso hablamos de lo
que acaba de suceder de lo que acaba de
pasar de lo que acabamos de ver
pero desde otro lugar porque nos entra
nos modifica nos provoca
pero lo permitimos porque es mentira es
ficción no existe
y esto es una manera de ir rompiendo con
los tabúes porque algo deja de ser un
tabú cuando la gente escucha cuando la
gente habla ponen como un debate y
construye pero esto no es nada nuevo
cuantos músicos escriben sus letras y su
música para canalizar sus sentimientos
cuantos poetas a lo largo de la historia
hablan de amar a una persona del mismo
sexo
cuantos pintores las van sus miedos
cuantos actores hay gente que baila hay
gente que que dibuja hay gente que que
cocina que escribe cuentos
sin duda la escritura y la
interpretación son un vehículo perfecto
aunque nadie nunca lo lea y aunque esa
obra de teatro nunca se vaya a poner en
pie pero el hecho de trascender nuestras
experiencias en una expresión artística
ya nos ayuda a romper con nuestros
tabúes es el inicio de un camino que una
vez empezado es imposible no recorrer
porque nos sientan muy bien
hay un artista que se llama piero
manzoni
que hizo una obra que se llama de
artista
manson y introdujo 30 gramos de
en 90 latas
y las vendió por el valor de 30 gramos
de oro yo siempre ha dicho yo quiero
hacer eso transformar la en arte
y es que este ha sido uno de los mayores
descubrimientos que he hecho hasta el
momento el poder del arte de la ficción
para romper con los moldes establecidos
para
para inspirar y para transformar
y vosotros
qué está aquello que silencia jce y que
podéis transformar en el arte
[Aplausos]